six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's go next to our caller from the
nine one six area code caller from nine
one six go ahead hello
that's you um well I'm watching the show
for a little bit and somebody kind of
touched on where I was to ask you about
it was more or less like what did you
think moving forward
can you send rather than a Democrat
necessarily I'm not either I agree with
you that a lot of Democrats in office
now are a little more right than I am
personally but I do think they're our
best shot and if he's trying to change
what's happening so I was just curious
what you like what you personally are
giving you personally we're backing or
who you felt deserve to be back because
I'm looking right now like I mean I
don't I don't know what's going to go on
and as far as like the next election
because I don't see anybody from the
Democratic Party stepping up that's an
actually like so yours I mean who was I
backing and where or who am i backing
for what not necessarily who you were
backing but who are like who do you
intend to because I mean I've been into
politics only for a couple of years now
since around 2015 but I mean just
looking at what's going on now it just
looks like community Democrats are just
as lost as the Republicans
yeah I mean we don't know who's running
yet so it's hard to know who who I'm
going to back I'm gonna have to make
that call based on who runs I think just
based on my politics like I recently
took this I side with political quiz and
the people in in the Senate who I most
align with politically or Bernie Sanders
and Elizabeth Warren so if one of the
two of them runs and I don't see Bernie
Sanders my issue with him is that he's a
little too uh he wants to implement
policies that I don't think we're
necessarily ready for like he's a little
too left I mean which is ironic like I'm
a little like it's both for me like I I
see his appeal but I think the way he
speaks and talks it's it's it's okay
let's see if we can break that if I may
for a second can we let's see if we can
break that down you first said Bernie's
too far to the left but then you said
the way he speaks and talks are the
problem so let's go back to the hold on
hold on
on what issues is Bernie to your left
probably socially like as far as like
how we should treat each other and how I
mean I'm gay
so like I'm extremely liberal in some
areas but in other areas I find I'm
formal conservative but I like the way
that he is more inclusive
I enjoy the very um wants to sit down
have a conversation so socially where
does Bernie's policy seem too liberal
for your politics probably what it
starts giving it to economics yeah wait
wait wait wait wait let's take it step
by step
you said socially Bernie is to your left
that's socially you're to the right of
Bernie but now you're saying it's
economics that Bernie's to your left so
socially no no you misunderstood me
amazed
I'm socially Bernie's I'm aligned with
them I think people how like how you
would think I think you should I respect
and I enjoy good I don't know he watched
this is America by Sacha Baron Cohen and
he on it and he was one of the few that
did not he just go along with whatever
he said no no surely you and Bernie
agree economically where are you to the
right of Bern um economically I just
think that uh I think that you know I I
don't I don't know I'm not as educated
as you probably can you name a single
policy on which year to the right of
Bernie oh yeah I can't I know now that
I'm on the show that you know all that
information flips your mind I can't
remember exactly what the policy was but
you remember well it was a couple years
ago because when he was running for
president he was talking about it and he
mentioned you know did you mind if I uh
do a real quick checkup little bit too
long on the air because I don't I can't
yeah but I think I I would reconsider
whether you actually don't like Bernie
as a possible candidate because so far
we haven't identified any any
differences I really appreciate the call
that's a conversation that in my
personal life I've actually had with a
lot of people in it and it tends to go
off and exactly like that
sorry to everybody I didn't get to I am
out of time we will take calls again
thanks to everybody who called in thanks
to everybody who is holding
quick break and we continue with the
Friday show on the David Pakman show